hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith today's best picture
close-up takes you inside an Academy
screening of dallas buyers club with
Matthew McConaughey and the filmmakers
as they discuss the stories real-life
inspiration a friend of mine sent me an
article from the independent called
staying alive and it was about the
buyers clubs and the International gray
market which was developed by people
with AIDS to seek out alternative
medications and it talked about ron
woodruff NL he was smuggling these drugs
from around the world and setting up
this underground girl barilla clinic
called the dallas buyers club the
article was fascinating because I didn't
know this world existed when I went and
met him he was just this character like
knowing every man was somebody who would
not die you know does the spirit for
life the first person that really came
to my mind was Matthew it was good it
was intuition I mean I I felt like he
was just the perfect person for it and
it was sort of like the role of a
lifetime and and yes he is from Texas
and I just thought he sort of embodied
all of the qualities that Ron had and
you know he's inherently very likeable
and so I just thought it would be a
great fit there's something to
absolutely fight for and every single
scene and almost literal sense it was
actually life and death but this was a
it was it was very special from the
Treasury I think the toughest part is
creating a balance between these
different worlds but what naturally kind
of lent itself to us of this
relationship with these two Outsiders we
just wanted to put it in Ron's face and
we thought Ryan was the best way to do
it and you know so he couldn't look away
you know once he had HIV and he was now
himself considered an outcast he did
gained quite a bit compassion he didn't
lose who he was that same sob who by any
means necessary to get it done and I'm
looking out for myself that selfish guy
he's still remaining I mean he became
much more alive after
he got HIV he found a purpose after he
got HIV one is worried it's so hard
making movies just to get a movie made
so to make a movie that has you know so
much to say that's emotional and
provocative and moving and inspiring and
and then is poignant on top of it and
and is important is such an amazing
thing and just the outpouring of emails
that and people that have contacted me
that have you know thanked me for
bringing this movie into the world is
just it just really makes you feel
vindicated for what you do and for
telling great school like everybody up
here left skin in the game they were the
champions of this and some of the people
that aren't here and that makes me
properties i know everybody gave
everything they had to it we had so very
little to do so much right it was just
hard it was it was hard to watch these
guys go through what they were going
through it was it was a complicated
don't but I came out of it so excited by
what happened between action and cut and
getting to work with Matthew and I
really had the best seats in the house
to two of the best performance of the
year and it was a thrill want to keep up
to date on all the nominated films visit
Oscar com for complete coverage and look
for more inside the Oscars updates
coming soon